I would be lying if I said I'm fine I
have no choice but to concentrate on my
health at this moment
today Celine Dion announced she is
canceling all 42 stops of her upcoming
courage World Tour the decision comes
amidst her ongoing battle with the rare
and incurable neurological disease stiff
person syndrome quote even though it
breaks my heart it's best that we cancel
everything now until I'm really ready to
be back on stage again
Celine first told fans about her health
crisis last December in this emotional
video stiff person syndrome which
affects something like
one in a million people this is what's
been causing all of the spasms that I've
been having people can die from
complications from the disease it's
serious many people require Walkers
wheelchairs some people are are
bedridden they can have spasms so severe
that they break bones Celine has been
keeping a very low profile since
revealing the diagnosis she hasn't been
seen publicly since January of 2022 her
last personal photo was posted just over
a year ago on Mother's Day while
surrounded by her Three Sons
yet last month Celine did release her
first single since 2019 and her voice
sounds stronger than ever
Celine did admit that the title track
off the Priyanka Chopra rom-com love
again was recorded a while ago the 55
year old also makes her acting debut in
the film do you really believe in all
these things you sing you obviously know
nothing about it but despite all the
setbacks Celine remains optimistic she
will return to the stage quote I'm
working really hard to build back my
strength I want you all to know I'm not
giving up
we all go through tough times we get
sick we have to find inner strength and
life imposes things on you you have no
choice you have to deal with them
foreign